dunder-mifflin this is Pam Michael
what's wrong okay wait wait wait wait
Michael do you need me to call an
ambulance
okay wait I thought you said that you
were hurt hey whoa Michael okay Jim just
say again really loudly what happened
[Music]
you burned your foot on a foreman mill I
enjoy having breakfast in bed I like
waking up to the smell of bacon sue me
and since I don't have a butler I have
to do it myself
so most nights before I go to bed I will
lay six strips of bacon out on my George
Foreman grill then I go to sleep when I
wake up I plug in the grill I go back to
sleep again then I wake up to the smell
of crackling bacon it is delicious it's
good for me it's a perfect way to start
the day today I got up I stepped onto
the grill and a clamp down on my foot
that's it I don't see what's so hard to
believe about that I'm testkit okay I'll
be putting them everywhere and please
don't throw these out this is a radon
test kit please don't throw these out
see them all over the office Toby has
been leaving radon kits everywhere like
he owns the place the first time I threw
mine away I thought it was an ant trap
but I figured I'd rather live with ants
than with his creepy little disk the
second time I thought it was one of
those you know the things you turn over
and move like a cow thing but upon
closer examination it was another ant
trap so I threw it away and the third
time I did it out of spite
you're kidding me God you say right on a
silent but deadly
and then you
like me not to make farting noises with
my mouth what is this you know we're not
gonna die every time we're gonna die
boredom yeah right
and if I had a gun with two bullets and
I was in a room with hitler bin Laden
and Toby I would shoot Toby twice okay
all right really funny and then you went
too far
I would kill bin Laden and then Toby no
it's still okay geniuses how would you
do it yes it is true I Michael Scott I'm
signing up with an online dating service
thousands of people have done it and I
am going to do it
I need a username and I have a great one
little kid lover that way people will
know exactly where my priorities are at
hey cousin heard you're having money
problems no you didn't listen I got the
answer you declare bankruptcy all your
problems go away how would that help
Creed and monopoly you go bankrupt you
lose you don't go by monopoly man that
game is nuts
nobody just picks up
get-out-of-jail-free cards those things
cost thousands that is a good point
bankruptcy Michael is nature's do-over
it's a fresh start it's a clean slate
like the witness protection program
exotically I've always wanted to be in
the witness protection program fresh
start no debts no baggage far I got my
name picked out Lord Rupert Everton I
made a shipping merchant who raises
fancy dogs that's the life
I declare bankruptcy okay Wendy hot and
juicy redhead give this a try Wendy
hello Wendy this is Kevin's friend
Michael this isn't Wendy
oh I'm sorry could you put her on please
this is a Wendy's restaurant okay could
I just have a frosty and a baked potato
please I'll send somebody to pick it up
just have it ready well put it aside no
God no God please no no no what's wrong
Michael
if I could gum in my hair you do this
just stinks
don't touch it please don't touch it you
got a ton of dandruff okay let me be how
do you get going here I was walking in
and I noticed something shiny under
Stanley's car and I gotten under see
what it was and I messed up my hair all
for a stupid piece of tinfoil but best
case scenario you thought it was a
corner kill me right now we have peanut
butter in the kitchen I don't feel like
peanut butter
give me an Ice Cream Sandwich oh not for
you it's for your hair and it is 9:00
a.m.
no Dwight not the good peanut butter
people are gonna get mad hey hey hey
this is my hair we're talking about
smells good tastes good too Oh Donna
that's disgusting Wow a lot of calories
well just don't leave it on too long
keep massaging please Jim could you come
in here please
hi Jim
hello I am Harvey a computer Jim sucks
oh wow oh that's so rude I'm sorry I
can't control them yeah you can you know
I get Pam for this pam pam you look very
hot today
Pam meet Harvey this is Michael's new
friend great me so horny me love you
long Tim oh oh
that is gross who's long Tim long time
Neil oh boy long time oh well you should
bring along Tim in one day yeah you
ruined a funny joke you get out of my
office
bye Harvey boobs Phil recruited me to
sell these cards and now I am recruiting
you who was this guy again don't worry
about Phil he drives a Corvette he is
doing just fine
okay calling cards are the wave of the
future these things sell themselves
who's this calling cards anyway you know
what that's a nice attitude Ryan I'm
just helping you invest in your future
my friend it sounds like a
get-rich-quick scheme yes thank you you
will get rich quick we all will can you
lose a lot of money on that other
investment that one from the email you
know what Toby when the son of the
deposed King of Nigeria emails you
directly asking for help you help his
father ran the freaking country okay all
right so raise your hand if you want to
get rich all right No
how is this not a pyramid scheme all
right let me explain I get
phil has recruited me and another guy
now we are getting three people each the
more people to get involved the more
people who are investing the more money
we're all gonna make it's not a pyramid
scheme it is a it's not even a scheme
per se it's
I have to go make a call oh my life
Michael what's wrong everything's wrong
the stress of my modern office has
caused me to go into a depression
depression isn't that just a fancy word
for feeling bummed out Dwight you
ignorant [__] depression is a very
serious illness over 32,000 people
commit suicide every year according to a
2004 study is that the last year that
data was available yes my head is in
such pain and turmoil don't do anything
rash wait where are the warehouse guys I
didn't I didn't think you needed him for
this part okay that's you said to just
that's the whole point dummy okay I'm on
it
okay Michael's up on the roof and he's
acting strange my life Michael what's
wrong everything is wrong
Dwight the stress of my model office has
made me depressed depressed isn't that
just a fancy word for feeling
you